thank you so much to everyone you know
um he says uh we cannot really think the
team is working that hard and make power
even better as we speak the game is so
popular they had they've been updating
the server outages players as a number
of concurrent players across all
platforms exceeded 1.3 million the Epic
online service is currently
exeeding due to the unusually high load
work worldwide so it's been all they've
been on and popping the team is working
around the clock to try to substantiate
the need
it's crazy obviously what king would one
love is this game is also on Game Pass
in game
preview you know the devs have said for
now that you know it is um XBox and
steam and no PlayStation for right now
who knows what happens in the future but
they go by the old tweet um it's it's
crazy